I received a ton of emails about this, one
of the most common requests for segments I've
gotten over the last couple of weeks is from
people who write in and say some version of
I have a Trump conspiracy theorist, family
member or friend or coworker.
I don't know how to talk to them.
I don't want to make anybody angry.
But in some way, I feel the need to try to
knock some sense into them proverbially, not
physically.
And I don't even know where to start.
And in the past, depending on the relationship
with the person, I say, well, you have to
decide.
Your approach will depend on how aggressive
you're willing to get.
Are you willing to ruin this relationship?
If these are presumably people, you have to
continue to be around cordially because they're
coworkers or family members or friends that
you love and want to continue being around.
I believe the best approach is a sort of gentle,
probing Socratic method of questioning, asking
people to think about how they came to the
conclusions they came to.
And hopefully some fraction of them will say,
oh, the basis on which I've come to hold these
beliefs isn't that strong.
Let me let me sort of reexamine it.
That's the the best I've suggested we can
really hope for.
If you want to go with the gentle probing
idea, Charlie Wortzel wrote a really great
opinion piece in The New York Times called
How to Talk to Friends and Family who share
Conspiracy Theories, which contains a lot
of really important information.
And I thought we would go over some of the
basics.
And I recognize that when when I've talked
about a Socratic method of questioning, one
of the questions that comes up regularly is
what exactly are the types of questions that
I should be asking?
So let's start there.
First of all, almost exclusively, the best
place to start when someone shares a conspiracy
theory on Facebook or in person at Thanksgiving
or whatever the case may be, is where is the
information coming from?
Where did you where did you learn that?
How did you come to believe that thing that
you just told me?
This is useful because it opens the door to
later asking, and how do you know that you
can trust that source?
How do you know the information is trustworthy?
So it's useful for that reason.
It's also useful because it helps you understand
the sort of information environment.
Where are some people getting this stuff?
Some might be getting it from Facebook, others
may be hearing it at work.
So that's very important.
The next step, as I sort of alluded to, would
be asking people how they've determined that
the information is trustworthy.
How have they determined that their source
of information can be believed?
What about it makes it believable?
How would they know if it were not believable?
These are generally relatively inoffensive
questions that you can ask with a genuine
curiosity to establish their system of belief.
And they can get people to start.
They can get the the gears moving.
How do you identify something that would be
less believable?
And a lot of this is not necessarily for you
to understand their level of media literacy,
although that is useful.
But again, inject the idea that they need
a process for thinking about have I properly
vetted and evaluated the conspiracy or the
fake news that I'm sharing right now?
And then maybe the hardest part is to really
follow through on the assumption that if they're
a conspiracy theory was real, then what other
things would have to be real?
And this one requires a little more knowledge
and nuance.
Imagine that you're right about this conspiracy
theory.
Imagine that what you're saying is true.
What would happen next?
What are you anticipating it would mean in
terms of this or of that?
And there's a really good example.
I'll try to this is on my Twitter.
I'll try to re share it if I can find it.
I retweeted a really good Twitter thread that
I went over last week on a stream where there
was like a Hollywood screenwriter talking
to a conspiracy theorist woman back and forth
on Twitter.
And he actually did this.
He engaged with her ideas, which started with
there's a plan for Trump to remain president,
that she was posting this on January 21st.
Obviously, Trump was gone, but she was saying
there is a plan for Trump to remain president
after the inauguration.
And this guy started asking specific questions,
OK, how will it be carried out?
Through what mechanism will Trump be back
in office and Biden be gone?
Well, he's going to be arrested, OK, what
will he be arrested for?
And eventually, the woman came to the claim
that Joe Biden had actually already died and
been replaced with an imposter at some point
in the past.
And it was fascinating to see the questions
that followed, which included, oh, how did
Biden die?
Was it of natural causes disease or did somebody
kill him?
If he was killed, who killed him?
How is it covered up?
How many people would have needed to be involved
in that to replace Biden with an imposter,
with nobody knowing?
Why did they even need to kill him?
Like, in other words, if Biden was going to
steal the election?
Either way, why do you need a fake Biden to
steal the.
From Donald Trump, why not just have the real
Biden steal the election from Donald Trump
and although this particular woman was clearly
too far beyond reach, what was interesting
was that it was a really good example of the
types of questions that for some people can
actually get them to say.
Maybe there's something about this that doesn't
make sense.
Really important.
Last thought on this, just because a belief
isn't based on a solid foundation doesn't
mean people will give it up easily.
And remember that just because this idea,
this system doesn't work on one person doesn't
mean that it's the wrong method.
We looked at that focus group with 12 Trump
last week.
Only one of the 12 was willing to reexamine
his beliefs and see reason.
So this a lot of people aren't even open to
this.
But for those that are, I find that this method
seems to be the best one.
Let me know your thoughts.
If you've had success with this method, let
me know if you've failed with this method.
Also, let me know.
I'm on Twitter at Dipak The David Pakman Show
at David
Pakman
dot com